the Jewish holiday of Passover begins
tomorrow at sundown Indiana does the
Eight Day celebration full of tradition
of course and here to share with us the
meaning and some of the Customs once
again Rabbi Levi Harley from Shabbat of
Southern Nevada thanks for joining us
good to see you once again always good
morning there's lots to talk about so
first of all I mean we've got this thing
plate of goodies here
um but first for folks who don't know
the history explain the history of
Passover and what it means Passover the
story took place a little over 3 300
years ago the Jews were in Egypt and as
many times throughout our history
persecution started pharaoh and the
Egyptians Enslaved the Jews
the point was to they shouldn't we
should stop our growth back-breaking
labor Moses is born Moses is a savior
Moshe God says go to Pharaoh tell
pharaoh to redeem the Jews he goes to
Pharaoh Pharaoh refuses he's a stubborn
man and they bring 10 plagues upon Egypt
and the haggad of the story of Passover
discusses it at length blood frogs lice
Etc tenth plague come to some plague of
the killing of the firstborn and then
finally Fowler had enough he said Jews
time to go and he rushed them out of
Egypt he said gotta go they're packing
their stuff and they're packing some
bread they're baking bread the dough did
not have enough time to rise because
they were rushing so that's the matzah
the Mata the matzo bread they leave
Egypt splitting in the sea go receive
the Torah of the Bible in Mount Sinai so
let's talk more about the the Traditions
the Passover Traditions it's the food
obviously but there's there's a whole
lot more to it than that of course yeah
absolutely Passover seder the two
Passover seders it's Wednesday night and
Thursday night so when you're supposed
to sit down with your family with your
community and discuss the story it's
about educating our children so we'll do
a lot of different things different than
a traditional Sabbath dinner a
traditional Shabbat dinner to pique the
Curiosity of our children's they can ask
so we can give them answers and provide
the information and the history of the
story pass it along pass over pass it on
I like that wow so the Passover Vermont
says the flat bread okay yeah we eat
that the entire peso the entire Passover
but it spiritually tastes good yes
that's important the meaning we have the
Seder plate seder plate is there's the
more the bitter herbs reminds us the
bitterness of the enslavement the
harosas is supposed to remind you of the
mortar and the bricks when the Jews are
working this is what they're putting
together we have some other items that
represent the sacrifices that took place
in the times of the temple and then
again you have the Haggadah it's a long
story every year you got to repeat it um
and go through the story at length
describe the significance and the
meaning and the lessons for us in 2023
it's still important when you have the
four cups of wine as well four cups of
wine are grape juice that's the fun
right there yes
I guess that offsets the matzah or the
the length drinking four cups in their
Navy very quickly uh some of the local
celebrations that are happening here in
the valley there are over 10 Passover
seders taking place all over Las Vegas
you want to go on our website Reserve
now because it's getting getting kind of
close and if you need your matzah last
couple days we have until tomorrow night
let us know we'll get you your box of
matzah so you can celebrate the holiday
with us that is awesome I just have one
quick question and for the Gentiles is
this something that we can take part in
if we wanted to sign up you want to
learn more about the Seder you can check
out first of all go on our website see
all the information it's an intense
seder so a brace for impact but there's
a lot to learn and there's a lot that
everyone can take to their homes discuss
with their families and make the world a
better place indeed Rabbi I leave at
Harley from Shabbat Southern Nevada
thanks for joining us good to see you
once again always a pleasure thank you
we appreciate you thank you yeah